[Applause]
what if the moon suddenly began getting
closer to earth to the point where it
was on a collision course with our
planet what hurts' survived the crash or
what a crash even happen with the moon
get torn up by Earth's gravity what
would this crumbled-up moon look like
from Earth this is what if and here's
what would happen if the moon fell to
earth the moon is Earth's only natural
satellite and the largest object to
brighten our night sky it's the first
and only place beyond Earth where humans
have set foot the moon's gravitational
pull causes tides on earth tides that
might have been the encouragement for
life in our oceans to move on land this
pull also keeps earth from wobbling on
its axis making our climate relatively
stable in short the moon makes earth a
more livable place
what if it suddenly sped up and started
driving in Earth's direction the moon's
planned to destroy Earth by bumping into
it would break into pieces the moment it
reaches the Roche limit the moon itself
would shatter never making it to Earth's
surface and that's gonna look very
impressive the wait what is this Roche
limit in celestial mechanics it's the
point at which the gravity holding a
satellite together is weaker than the
tidal forces trying to pull it apart in
other words the moon can only get as
close as eighteen thousand four hundred
and seventy kilometers away from our
planet before buoy the tidal forces
would tear it apart all of the
footprints and flags we've left on the
moon all of its craters and valleys
would scatter to form a breathtaking
ring of debris above earth's equator
37,000 kilometers in diameter making
earth the second planet in the solar
system
after saturn to have this striking ring
of beauty the difference being that our
rings wouldn't last long the chunks of
our former satellite the moon would rain
down on earth it would be as if hundreds
of thousands of asteroids were falling
down on us and wiping out entire cities
in the process once the moon began its
trajectory towards the planet it would
increase the tidal impact it has on us
by the time it hit the Roche limit it
would be causing tides as high as
seventy six hundred metres our world
would be devastated by an army of
tsunamis ten times a day but for a short
time hardcore surfers would enjoy riding
some tasty waves on the other hand this
might be a solution to global warming
with the moon coming closer and closer
Earth's rotation would speed up our days
will become shorter and shorter global
temperatures would go down and no one
would worry about climate change anymore
unless asteroids burned the earth to a
crisp then there would be no one to
worry about anything I really wouldn't
worry about it anyway in fact the moon
is drifting away from us at a rate of
four centimeters per year so it's
unlikely we'll get to see those pretty
saturn-like rings here on earth
[Music]